to Long climb daily I'm Jesse Weber
prosecutors in Alec Murdoch's murder
trial say he killed his wife Maggie and
youngest son Paul at their country home
in 2021 and now the state has called its
last witnesses to rebut the claims made
by the defense long crimes and Jeanette
Levy has details on who the prosecution
called First and why
I love Paul very much I thought I knew
who Alex was I did not Ronnie Crosby
Alec Murdoch's former law partner and
family friend was the first witness the
state called in rebuttal when was the
first time you've heard the defendant's
latest story admitting that he was in
fact at the kennels minister
I haven't watched uh all of this trial
uh like a lot of people have but when I
heard that um
Ellie was taking the stand I believe it
was last
Thursday on cross-examination Alec
Murdoch's attorney dick harputlian
implied Crosby was biased because
Murdoch stole from clients and destroyed
their Law Firm are you angry at him for
stealing your money I have no feeling
one way or the other I don't have any
feeling about Alec Murdoch betraying you
and stealing your money you're I admire
you I don't know that I could look
beyond that forensic pathologist Dr
Ellen Riemer took the stand again to
rebut a defense expert who said her
Claim about Paul Murdoch's gunshot wound
to the Head being an exit wound was
wrong is there any way that could have
been a contact wound to the top of the
head no on cross-examination harputland
we don't have shattering of every phone
we don't have shattering of the face so
why didn't you shave the head
why didn't I shave are you looking for
any if if much of the skull is still
there
look my determination I didn't shave the
head because I I was confident that that
was an exit wound on the right side of
the top of the head after testimony
concludes the jury will be taken to
Moselle the 1700 acre property where
Paul and Maggie Murdock were murdered
for Law and crime daily I'm Anjanette
Levy in Walterboro South Carolina
the fourth reply witness call was a
digital forensics examiner who works
with the Charleston County Sheriff's
Office as well as the Secret Service and
he had done experiments to determine how
you have to make an iPhone I move an
iPhone to activate the screen's waking
feature Murdoch's defense team wanted to
strike this testimony they say he's not
actually an expert the judge overruled
that but attorney Phil Barber
nonetheless hammering home the point
so you were unable to find any actual
data on it so you resorted to throwing
your phone around alone was anyone with
you when you did this uh no sir I was
alone in my office
so you're alone in your office throwing
the phone around taking no measurements
recording nothing over the weekend and
then you come in here and testify as an
expert as to what the phone will do
that's correct and testify that it's
different than what we've seen it do
right here in this corporate that's
correct
have you ever done this anything like
this before you'd mentioned testifying
six times before did you ever resist
your expert testimony in any other case
when my expert testimony in other cases
was always about cell phone reports and
the data contained therein I've never
actually done physical experimentation
to come up with a realistic result so
you that your your previous experience
was extracting data from cell phones is
that accurate correct is that what
you're trained to do yes sir
um the the training that was listed it
was to extract data from a cell phone
yes sir
um
are you a an engineer no sir do you have
any certification in engineering no sir
do you have any degree academic
qualifications in engineering no sir
have you ever worked as an engineer no
sir you're trained in extracting data
from the cell phone that's correct and
when it comes to tossing it around and
seeing how it moves you don't know
anything more than anyone else do you no
sir
okay I'm joined right now by my co-host
and former trial Attorney Terry Austin
as well as special guest litigator
Richard schoenstein Rich I'll start with
you welcome to the program gotta start
with the digital friends examiner and he
says he's an expert in data extraction
maybe not so much an expert in some of
the stuff he testified to feels like a
win for the defense look Jesse I'm an
expert I can toss my cell phone around I
mean that was crazy that was a terrible
idea by by the prosecution to put him on
he literally sat in his office over the
weekend threw a cell phone around we
don't even know if it was the same kind
of cell phone that Maggie Murdock had
it's not scientific at all that was a
crazy idea a big fail for the
prosecution they had some better moments
today but that wasn't one of them yeah
and he did it all with a straight face
on the stand Terry let's talk about Dr
Riemer okay forensic pathologist how do
you think she held up during
cross-examination you think that the
defense scored any points there you know
I think Dr Riemer was better when she
was on the first time I think this time
she was a little bit rattled but that
jury likes her she has this professor
type you know
demeanor about her and I think they like
that and I do think however that the
defense made a couple of points they
tried to say that her examination was
shabby and shoddy and the fact that she
didn't take enough photographs she
didn't x-ray that brain and I think she
took offense to that I think that's why
she got a little bit upset and she came
across the way she did I think
substantively the defense was trying to
say that the angle and that the you know
contact wound to the head was a
possibility she said it wasn't I think
overall she still came out on top and
there's a possibility the jury might
wash all the experts out and not even
consider this testimony when they
ultimately go to their deliberations now
our coverage of this double murder trial
isn't done still ahead on Long Prime
daily we're taking a look at how you our
viewers are reacting to today's
testimony and we're answering your
questions when we come back we're
hearing more testimony from an attorney
with Alec Murdoch's former Law Firm who
did not like the way defense attorney
dick karpoulian was questioning him stay
with us
foreign
[Music]
family murders in South Carolina
continues now with a fiery
cross-examination Alec Murdoch's former
law partner Ronnie Crosby testified
earlier in the trial and he was called
back again defense attorney dick
harpootley implied that Crosby may have
testified out of spite in connection
with Murdoch's Financial crimes
have you had to come out of pocket to
pay back the money he stole
yes and if you how much I I don't tell
me you don't know
well we're still counting Mr Harpoon how
much have you paid so far
we have had to borrow Millions to pay
back how much have you had to come out
of pocket well when you bore it you got
to pay it back and I couldn't tell you
how much has exactly been paid back uh
as of we sit here today but yes and if
you're implying that I would come in
here and somehow shade truth in any way
because of that that's I would take High
offense with that Mr Harpoon learned
about your higher fans are you angry at
him for stealing your money I have no
feeling one way or the other
feeling about Alec Murdoch betraying you
and stealing your money your
your I admire you I don't know that I
could look beyond that direction
it is sustained there's not a question
and jurious to disregard the argument
you are not angry with Alec murder I
have had anger with him extreme anger Mr
harputin because of what he did to my
Law Firm my partners my client his
clients our clients what he did to his
family what he's did to so many people
yes I experienced a lot of anger but you
can't walk around with anger you have to
find a way to deal with it and move
forward and I have done that and if you
suggest you are dead wrong if you think
I've come in here and told this jury
something because of money when we we're
talking about two people who were
brutally murdered then you're you're
headed in the wrong direction
[Music]
we're finishing off today's show back in
Walterboro South Carolina as the case
dwindles down and Alec Murdoch's double
murder trial the outcome is ultimately
is ultimately up to a 12-person jury and
you our viewers have been sharing your
predictions at home so on the first day
of the prosecution's rebuttal case
here's where you believe the trial is
headed based on our YouTube poll so 67
of you 67 believe that Murdoch is guilty
15 percent believe he's not guilty and
17 percent are still undecided until all
the evidence is in now this is a shift
from the end of Murdoch's testimony on
Friday where 66 percent of the viewers
said that Murdoch was guilty 11 said not
guilty and 22 percent were leaning
towards a hung jury or undecided or
combined so it's clear that no one can
predict the minds of those 12 people in
the jury box but the good news is we
have boots on the ground observing the
jury's movements in the courtroom day in
and day out so here's long crimes very
own and Jeanette Levy and Gigi McKelvey
to give us Tuesday's takeaways
they were watching you know I thought
for a minute we were going to break out
the boxing gloves and just go at it with
a couple of these rebuttal Witnesses but
yeah very engaged it's been a little
heated at times a little unpredictable
and Ronnie Crosby I think definitely
resonated with that jury because his
feelings are so valid and if you've ever
been betrayed not on the scale most of
us haven't been betrayed like this but
man what a credible witness for the
state
very see how Alec Murdoch is acting
during the trial yeah they have a great
view I mean they can look right over at
him and oftentimes they do when certain
testimony comes up today they have
glanced over several times with each
witness to see I guess his reaction I I
think you said thought that some of the
jurors some of the female jurors didn't
like the way that dick harputlian was
questioning Dr Riemer yeah and some of
the male jurors as well I mean they just
seem really irritated I don't think that
it it's always the best method to yell
at a nice little lady who's a
pathologist it kind of kind of gets old
really quick but yeah I did see some
strong reactions from the jury and and I
think everybody harpootlian and the
witness were frustrated with each other
it was really obvious really tense in
that room today
yeah 10 very tense that's a good way to
describe it all right final discussion
is going to include your viewer
questions from our YouTube channel to
try to clear up any confusion you might
have about the case completely
understandable Rich will start with you
our first question comes from Michael
Rolfe what instructions will the jury
get before the crime scene visit and
what is the defense hope for them to
take away from that visit well Michael I
think the jury will be told it's just a
viewing you're not there first of all
the jurors can't talk to each other they
can't talk to each other to the end of
the case they can't experiment they
can't see if their cell phones get
reception at the kennel or other
questions they have all they can do is
look around it's a crime scene visit the
defense I think is hoping that they take
away that it's a huge property and I
think the defense once the jurors
specifically to believe that it would be
possible Alec Murdock could be back at
the house not hearing a double homicide
going on at the kennels yep that
distance is important all right Terry we
have another question from Emmy I don't
think it's the medical examiner if the
jury believes there are two Shooters
would they be expected to equip Murdoch
even if they believe he's one of the
shooters that's a good question great
question Amy listen if they believe that
Alec Murdock shot either Maggie or Paul
he will not be acquitted he will be
convicted of murder they could think
there are two three four five Shooters
out there the way they're going to get
those jury forms it's going to be
separate there are four counts two
charges for murder and two charges for
possession of that gun and using it in a
violent crime and if they determined
that he had one gun and he shot either
one of them he will be convicted it has
to be unanimous and that's the issue
right here are you going to get all 12
of them to agree we got the best viewers
great questions so attentive and we'll
keep them coming here on the daily Terry
rich thank you both so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America